[Musique]
tout le monde sait qu'à la mort de
charlemagne son empire va être divisé
tout comme l'a toujours été la royauté
franck les carolingiens devons régner
sur l'europe quasiment charlemagne
empereur d'occident de 750 de l'an 750
jusqu'au xix ème siècle et que de cette
division émergera un nouvel ordre
avec l'avènement d'une nouvelle famille
à l'ouest du rhin les capétiens
mais la passation de pouvoir n'a pas été
simple et s'étend sur près de deux
siècles et capétiens vent régnié de 987
et en passant jusqu'aux orléans qui sont
également des capétiens jusqu'en 1848 la
période capétienne c'est la période où
est une expression qui fait qui fait
florès c'est le roi passé dit un compte
mais qui t'a fait compter elle compte
répond mais est toi qui t'a fait roi
[Musique]
tout d'abord un nouvel empereur va
succéder à charlemagne en 814 aux morts
successives de ses fils aîné le grand
charles répond par la nomination de son
dernier fils louis au titre impérial d
mais le premier louis de l'histoire de
france va rechercher une légitimité sans
délégation
il organise son sacre trois ans plus
tard en faisant venir le papa à reims en
816 il devient ainsi le premier monarque
sacrés à reims
[Musique]
louis est un nom qui dérive de la
latinisation du nom francs clovis le
dernier carolingien avoir la main sur
lampy reconstitué par son illustre père
est ainsi directement rattaché au 1er
mai au 20 juin premier roi du peuple
francs unifiée après l'effritement de
l'empiré carolingien une nouvelle
dynastie va s'installer durablement sur
le trône de la partie occidentale de
l'état créé par charlemagne
oh
la consolidation du pouvoir des
capétiens s'effectuera pendant un xième
siècle marqué par deux événements qui
vont influencer durablement la société
du moyen-âge
[Musique]
la conquête de l'angleterre par
guillaume le conquérant et la première
croisade
la mort de charlemagne ne marque pas le
début d'une chute inexorable sans aucun
soubresaut de la part de sa descendance
son fils louis consolide dans un premier
temps son pouvoir en s'appuyant sur
l'église de son vivant on le surnomme le
pieux
la puissance la plus ancienne et la plus
stable est celle des évêques
elle s'organise à partir d'un réseau qui
a fait ses preuves celui des cités
construites sur le modèle romain mais de
nouvelles villes apparaissent
s'articulant autour de grands monastères
qui constitue bientôt un réseau soutenu
par l'empereur lui-même suivant la règle
réformée de saint-benoît ses monastères
font construire des abbatiale des
églises dont l'iconographie permet
l'établissement des lieux culturels
structurants
la population laïque est encadré par ses
modèles de pureté l empire en reste
unifier pendant un temps pendant un
temps seulement les disparités vont
bientôt s'imposer
l'héritage de charlemagne ne peut
s'étendre davantage
il manque de dynamisme tout l'occident
et chrétiens le seul défi et bientôt de
défendre les acquis
défendre les acquis car des embarcations
profil est très légère
très coloré aussi dont le fonds permet
de naviguer en eaux douces comme
d'affronter des lames de fond commence à
apparaître régulièrement sur tout le
pourtour du littoral de la terre des
francs des monstres en guise de proue
ces navires sont manoeuvrés par des
hommes qui cherchent à survivre
ce sont les vikings on va voir jaillir
des embarcations rapides nerveuse légère
que l'on va surnommé à tort qu'on va
nommer à tort les drakkars parce que les
drakkars mais que la tête du dragon qui
est à l'avant mais que scientifiquement
on appelle des échecs et à bord de ces
bateaux et lian li ap lé géant blond les
gens en blanc qui ont des mines
patibulaires et des noms qui sont aussi
patibulaire que leurs airs puisque dana
qui s'appelle ragnar aux culottes poilus
un autre s'appelle siegfried aux dents
noires des marchands devenu pillards
remarquable marins des païens qui cède à
la tentation de toutes les richesses qui
s'accumulent dans les monastères de
grande-bretagne et de france y ils sont
pas bien ils ont leurs dieux barbares
les dieux venus du nord car ils viennent
de septentrion c'est à dire du grand
nord de dan du danemark de norvège de
suède etc
et il adore odin si bien que quand ils
arrivent sur nos côtes
il s'enfonce dans les cours d'eau dans
les fleuves dans le dans les rivières
les truies des abeilles qu ils violent
il fuit la misère de leur terre natale
et sème la panique dans un premier temps
ils ruinent le commerce
l'essentiel étant fluvial comme c'était
de très fins navigateur tout le
vocabulaire maritime le vocabulaire leur
dois beaucoup lé le bâbord le tribord le
hauban la carlingue
tout ça ce sont des mots venus du
victimes des vikings eh bien ils
navigueront jusqu'en sicile où ils vont
même créé des royaumes ou jusqu'en
russie le maurupt otsi qu'il a donnée
russie est un mot d'origine bric et il
provoque un terrible épisode avec son
cortège de famine ces riches alors des
forteresses de bois et de terre
à l'initiative de guerriers locaux et
non d'un roi encore moins d'un empereur
qui perd tout contrôle
le responsable de cette prise
d'initiative locale prend le statut de
seigneur c'est la mort ce de la mise en
place d'un nouveau système le système
féodal les temps deviennent trouble les
hommes resserre les liens de proche en
proche par des serments de fidélité
tout le monde a besoin d'un chef ne
serait ce qu'un chef de clan
c'est dans ce contexte de crise que se
prépare la succession de louer des
tensions apparaissent entre ses trois
fils lothaire l'aîné louis germanique
est issu de son second mariage
le dernier petit fils de charlemagne
charles le chauve
si un rapprochement s'effectue entre
deux des frères
ce n'est pas entre les deux issus de la
même mère mais entre les deux plus
jeunes au détriment de l'aîné qui a
l'ambition de succéder à son père et à
son grand père comme empereur d'un état
digne de ce titre et non morcelé en
trois parties
le conflit n'est pas résolu quand meurt
louis le pieux en 840
il laisse en héritage un état d unis par
des tensions internes fratricide est
menacée par les raids des vikings venus
du nord de l'europe en 842 l'alliance
entre les deux plus jeunes frères se
renforce
charles le chauve et louis le germanique
prête réciproquement les serments de
strasbourg prononcé en langue romane et
en langues germaniques afin d'être
compris par les troupes de l'ouest comme
de l'est de la france y lothaire est
contraint de céder s'ils conservent le
titre d'empereur
il n'est qu'honorifique l'empiré lui
bien divisé lors du partage de verdun en
trois entités se dessine alors italie
germany et gaulle ou france il
à la mort de l'auteur en 855 le titre
d'empereur et transmis à son fils aîné
louis ii le jeune et son territoire
partagé une nouvelle fois entre ses
trois fils l'empereur est maintenant
moins puissant que ses deux oncles louis
le germanique et charles le chauve
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
les hostilités reprennent entre les deux
fils survivant de louis le pieux chaque
royaume s'assure de la fidélité des
seigneurs dont il a besoin pour mener
une guerre et défendre son territoire
pour conserver un rapport de force
favorable
chacun concède petit à petit de sa
puissance publique qu'il est censé
incarner et permettent au système féodal
de se substituer peu à peu au système
carrelage 1
on ne se dispute pas tant des
territoires que des comptes et des
abbayes des hommes et leur fidélité
non seulement les charges laïque
deviennent très d'iter mais les charges
spirituelle se laïcise et s'entiche du
mêmes travers l'hérédité
comme elles ne peuvent pas se
transmettre de père en fils ces charges
demeurent dans la même famille par le
biais du népotisme
l'abbé laïque un grand seigneur féodal
transmet son honneur à son neveu qui
n'est autre que son fils cadet dans
certains cas les seniors locaux
responsables de la sécurité de la
population face aux reds vikings ce
matin fait au départ des seniors
régionaux qui ont mis la main sur toutes
les sources de revenus comptez zerby
c'est la constitution d'une pyramide
féodal des vassaux au suzerain
dans le royaume de charles schwab un
parti d'aristocrates se forme autour de
robert lefort compte de touré danger m
d'abbaye considérable et grands chefs de
guerre en 864 en échange de sa fidélité
charles le chauve lui confie le comté de
paris robert lefort meurt deux ans plus
tard en combattant les normands mais
robert aura une descendance
kpc celui qui a été choisi puisqu'il a
été élu par les grands pour devenir roi
il est de la famille dérobé retiens
c'est à dire que son ancêtre remonte au
milieu du 9ème siècle c'était robert
lefort qui avait lutté contre les
normands et qui avait été d'ailleurs
victorieux avant de mourir d'ailleurs en
866 et conques est d'ailleurs considéré
comme un martyr et connu sous le nom de
mac abbé et ce robert tient c'est lui
qui est le vrai fondateur de l'adie de
la dynastie ses fils ont régné sur le
royaume
car la rhyolite alors élective ce sont
eux qui peu à peu ça prend énormément de
temps et à plusieurs rois il ya
plusieurs plusieurs dynasties et peu ce
sont ceux qui imposent et d un peu par
la géographie aussi puisqu'ils sont au
centre du royaume même si l'artère à eux
leurs fiefs sont assez petit et le
resteront pendant une centaine d'années
et ils essayent de s'installer
le rapport de force s'est de nouveau
stabilisé entre francis germany les deux
fils de louis le pieux se réconcilient
d'ailleurs en 870 ils se partagent la
partie septentrionale du royaume de leur
neveu si ce dernier conserve le titre
d'empereur son domaine ne peut plus
décemment porter le nom d' empire
longtemps considérée comme avant tout la
mort ce d'un déclin celui de la
puissance carolingienne et de l'héritage
de charlemagne le partage de verdun est
maintenant plutôt perçu comme le début
d'une double construction celle des
nations françaises et allemandes
c'est le retour à un cadre politique
économique et culturel aux dimensions
plus adapté aux réalités ethniques et
c'est donc tout naturellement la part
italienne qui se morcelle la première
elle qui n'a pas d'identité à la
différence de la france y où se
regroupent les fronts de l'ouest plus
latinisé que leurs cousins de l'est qui
se fédèrent à l'intérieur de la germanie
à partir de 870 charles le chauve peut
faire figure de premier roi de france
il en a sûrement pas conscience
[Musique]
non
en 875 après la mort de son neveu
empereur charles le chauve hérite du
trône impérial ainsi que des royaume
d'italie et de provence le jour de noël
875 à rome 75 ans exactement après le
couronnement de charlemagne
il est couronné empereur par le pape
ce dernier l'appel au secours deux ans
plus tard afin de défendre rome contre
la menace des musulmans
si les raids des vikings a fait le nord
de l'europe et tout le littoral
atlantique la méditerranée et sous la
menace permanente des raids musulmans
tandis que le roi de france y a déjà
bien du mal à contenir les assauts des
païens du nord
comment pourrait-il s'aventurer à
protéger l'italie
si charles est couronné empereur en 1875
il meurt deux ans plus tard en voulant
défendre un territoire qu'il ne peut
plus contrôler et l'état auquel on donne
le nom de francs si c'est déjà
réorganisé non plus autour d'aix la
chapelle
l'ancienne capitale de l'empiré de
charlemagne mais autour de reims de
paris et de saint denis
[Musique]
c'est ici que robert lefort s'implanter
solidement et que ses successeurs seront
faire fructifier son héritage
robert lefort c'est le premier des
dérobert siens c'est lui qui va avoir le
le premier l'idée de la supériorité des
ducs de france c'est à dire pour aider à
d'ile-de-france qui sont au centre du
royaume et qui sont en quelque sorte
candidats à la la création d'une
monarchie française qui sera héritière à
la fois de la gaule romaine et des
royaumes francs et tout ça va créer
véritablement la monarchie française
[Musique]
la france y ne sera elle jamais morcelé
elle aura toujours un unique souverain
il est déjà trop tard pour que les
carolingiens puisse appuyer une bonne
fois pour toutes sur la mystique du
sacre ou encore trop tôt la france est
encore en quête d'identité
[Musique]
les années qui suivent la mort de
charles de chauffe sont celles où les
vikings lancent leur campagne les plus
dévastatrices les descendants de charles
le chauve se succèdent rapidement
jusqu'à charles le gros fils de louis le
germanique
si le carolingien des faits quelquefois
les vikings il essaie de trouver un
compromis quand il menace paris ce2
compte de paris et fils de robert lefort
qui résiste à l'envahisseur en 885 et
sauve la ville du péril normand face à
la menace païenne le peuple chrétien ne
semble plus pouvoir compter sur les
carolingiens si ces vikings peuvent être
considérés comme une punition divine
les descendants de charlemagne ne passe
pas le test avec succès à la mort de
charles de gros en 888 c'est eux deux
que les grands du royaume choisissent
pour roy alléguant que l'héritier des
carolingiens charles de simple et trop
jeune pour régner
ed sacré roi des francs à compiègne le
29 février puis de nouveau couronné à
reims le 13 novembre
il peut accepter cette responsabilité
car il a un frère robert effectivement
de volants rois
il concède son comté mais sa famille
peut le conserver par l'intermédiaire de
robert ainsi sa dynastie ne perd pas
l'essentiel dans ce système féodal qui
n'est pas le titre de roi mais le titre
de comte de paris avec toutes ses
abbayes et ses revenus et tous les
hommes qui sont rattachés par un serment
de fidélité eux peut être roi sans
cesser d'être chef de clan
les grands qui ont élu eudes devons
chercher qu'à l'affaiblir
un roi qui centraliserait non plus
symboliquement le pouvoir mail
exercerait réellement leur ferait perdre
leur influence dans le système féodal
pas question de substituer au système
carolingien un système robert siens qui
contrôlerait tout
[Musique]
à la mort de sde le carolingien charles
le simple récupère le trône de toute
façon eu deux n'a pas de fils et son
frère n'en a pas encore mais cela ne va
plus tarder eudes et ensevelis à saint
denis en 898
c'est donc un carolingien qui en 911
règle le problème vikings en cédant à
leur chef
re long une partie de son territoire
rouen en échange rôle on devient robert
en se baptisant et en rendant hommage au
roi de france
les normands car ce sont les normands
les vikings nordman les hommes noirs
venus du nord
et ces gens là vont finir par
s'installer définitivement dans ce qui
était la neustrie et qui va devenir la
normandie en 911 quand le roi de france
charles le simple va dire à rollon au
grand patron rollon le chef des vikings
bon je voulais installez vous ici et
puis vivons en bonne compagnie les uns
avec les autres et c'est ce que va faire
au long
une grande date pour l'histoire de
france et pour l'histoire de
l'angleterre puisque débute sur cette
terre le règne d'une dynastie qui va
marquer les deux côtés de la manche
l'organisation politique des deux états
en construction
des normands selon la la grande
tradition voulant que les conquérants
soit conquis ils sont devenus tellement
gallo-romain qu'ils ont envisagé des
extensions delà du royaume franc de
leurs traditions de leur qualité de vie
de leur capacité à mettre en valeur les
espaces et ils ont voulu faire une
extension en angleterre charles devient
une menace en répondant au besoin de
renouveau de la spiritualité en occident
il pourrait mettre à mal un des
principes de l'organisation de la
féodalité des 9e et 10e siècle à savoir
la laïcisation des charges spirituel les
grands féodaux sorte effectivement sur
le terrain à une contre offensive menée
par un ordre monastique suivant la règle
bénédictine réformer et dont la
construction de la première basyan de la
maison mère commence à cluny en 910
[Musique]
les historiens sont d'accord aujourd'hui
pour lire il s'agit dans la fondation
par louis le pieux est le fils de
charges by car comme ça fondé et
favoriser beaucoup d'autres abbey dans
mon situant au début du neuvième siècle
le nouveau départ ça a été avec
l'acceptation ou imposition à moissac de
la réforme cluny la grande abbaye
bourguignonne et c'est l'abbé odilon 5e
abbé de cluny qui a mis à moissac était
à ce moment là en difficulté un de ses
amis auvergnat comme lui
durand de bredon qui a donc instauré la
réforme judiciaire et qui était à
l'origine du siècle d'or de la baie des
11e et 12e siècle le cloître a été
érigée en l'an 1100 il n'ya pas au monde
de cloître antérieur et puis c'est un
joueur tribu cette beauté au fait de du
nombre et de la qualité des chapiteaux
et en particulier des chapiteaux
historiés
en 922 charles le simple est purement
déposés ce qui permet un retour rapide
sur le trône de roi des francs du comte
de paris robert premier frère de hull d
923 celui-ci décédant sans héritier en
âge de gouverner on préfère même faire
passer la couronne sur la tête du duc de
bourgogne
raul plutôt que sur un carolingien
capable d'incarner le pouvoir à
l'échelle de la france si finalement la
couronne revient à 1 carolingien en 936
les trois derniers carolingien à se
succéder vont renforcer le pouvoir royal
l'ordre monastique issus de cluny
prospère apportant des réponses au chaos
de ces siècles
[Musique]
la construction de cluny deux débutants
cette abbaye qui est aux confins du
royaume de france et de lentilles
cette abbaye va essaimer les deux
nations vont affluer
il ya quand même 5000 donation en un
siècle ont cette énorme bond et par
conséquent il n'y a pas que des
aristocrates un bon alors c'est à cette
abbaye va essaimer donc avoir des
filiales à créer un réseau très
centralisé d'ailleurs elle va développer
en france dans le royaume de france
une une hiérarchie justement et une
cette toile d'araignée qui est très
importante qui fait qu' il y a de
l'ordre à l'est du rhin apparaît un
empereur germanique au ton premier est
élu par ses troupes et couronné empereur
des romains par le pape en 962 pendant
ce temps les normands ont appris le
français ne parlent plus que cette
langue
l'administration du duché est exemplaire
ce territoire est en paix
le dernier carolingien louis 5 meur à 20
ans d'une mauvaise chute de cheval le 22
mai 1987 une dernière fois plutôt que
d'élire son oncle carolingien qui aurait
pu devenir puissants les gros se tourner
vers le duc de france hugues que l'on
surnomme capet en raison de la cad
qu'ils aiment porter des capétiens la
dynastie des capétiens doit son nom à
une cape et qui a été élu roi de france
en en lan 987 cap et parce qu'il portait
toujours une petite cape c'était son
surnom surnom qui restera d'ailleurs
jusqu'à la révolution puisque les
révolutionnaires d'hirondelles louis
saez monsieur cap et en souvenirs donc
de son patronyme
il daterait éventuellement de robert
lefort dont j'ai parlé le premier
ancêtre si vous voulez celui qui m'aura
866 en luttant contre les normands qui
aurait obtenu l'année d'avant à 865 de
l'empereur l'abbaye de saint martin de
tours comme compte à b1 et là était
conservé la chape de saint-martin et
l'histoire du manteau partager et ses
fils en ont hérité et en particulier le
père de cap et hugues 1 qui s'appelait
hugo cie qui est mort quand hugues capet
avait 15 ans et il a il a transmis à
hugues capet un son c'est ce pouvoir du
cap et devient roi parce qu'il semble
plus facilement manipulable et moins
puissants son royaume se cantonne à
l'île de france
le roi c'est le duc de france est un
c'est un chef
une famille noble plus un peu plus
prestigieuses que les autres mais à
peine plus prestigieux c'est une c on
est loin de là la grande organisation
carolingienne là on est on arrive avec
les capétiens dans l'organisation de la
suprématie des seigneurs les uns par
rapport aux autres
le roi se cantonne à ce qu'on appelle
son domaine le domaine royal c'est à
dire l'ensemble des terres et des droits
sur lesquels il exerce son pouvoir
directement c'est sa principauté à lui
mais autour il y en a d'autres
autrement dit on à un royaume qui est
constitué d'une mosaïque deux principaux
ter etc principauté fonctionne
exactement de la même façon que la
principauté royal c'est à dire que on
n'y a institué des des princes qui se
transmettent le pouvoir de façon
désormais héréditaire à partir du 11e
siècle
ces princes connaissent évidemment une
structure de société féodaux vassalli qu
il concède une partie de leur territoire
à des seigneurs qui sont inférieures en
dans le rang de l'aristocratie et
qu'est-ce qui leur conseille le concept
des fiefs 1 et dans ses fiefs
il peut y avoir des droits de justice un
château etc
[Musique]
comment ils gouvernent le roi pas par
des actes législatifs mais par des
chartes ponctuelles donner à tel ou tel
seigneur laïque ou ecclésiastiques
ces chartes sont le fruit d'une requête
le plus souvent et la charte comporte le
plus souvent un don c'est à dire que
l'acte politique est d'abord un acte de
générosité octroyé par le roi
cela implique que la cour du roi est un
réceptacle de demandes de requêtes de la
part de qui essentiellement des
aristocrates
mais la cour des capétiens des premiers
capétiens surtout je l'imaginé comme un
lieu assez libre d'accès pour la
personne royale
le roi va s'entourer petit à petit de
chances d'un chancelier 1 pour ces
écritures d'un connétable d'un sénéchal
de bouteiller
mais ces offices vous le voyez sont des
offices qui sont à cheval qui mêle
intimement le privé et le public
ce sont des offices de maison de bouche
enfin le bouthillier et c'est clair
c'est celui qui s'occupe aussi de la ddt
de la table et des vins 1
voilà mais en même temps il peut prendre
des décisions voyaient ils font partie
de l'entourage et ils ont un titre
et qui sont ces officiers c'est la fine
fleur de l'aristocratie d'île de france
qui vient entré au service de la de la
monarchie capétienne
des capétiens direct au valois puiseaux
bourbon pendant huit siècles ce royaume
allait s'agrandir tout en ayant à sa
tête un représentant de la même famille
celle dont le premier représentant avait
été choisi parce qu'il semblait faible
les capétiens ans vont régner jusqu'en
1848 avec louis philippe alors avec
évidemment les capétiens direct ensuite
seule la branche sera la branche des
valois ensuite la branche des bourbons
et puis l'on terminera avec la branche d
orléans cette dynastie capétienne elle
durera très longtemps et elle est le
fruit de milan de guerre de discussion
de désordre et du passage de la gaule
romane à la gaule franck on s'aperçoit
que c'est là que se construit la france
est en 987 avec ap on peut parler de
france
mais plutôt que de conquérir comme
clovis et charlemagne hughes avait
choisi de durée il instaure des noëls
987 la règle de la primogéniture mal en
associant au trône son fils aîné robert
2 pendant plus de deux siècles les
successeurs du cap et utilisons cette
stratégie afin de stabiliser le pouvoir
est de pérenniser la dynastie ils feront
sacré de leur vivant leur fils aîné est
ainsi vont correspondre pour les siècles
à venir deux idées l'idée de la france
et l'idée du sacre désormais le sacre
suis un certain ordre
autrement dit chaque fois qu'un roi
arrive au pouvoir il est sacré selon un
ordre d'eau le terme latin est difficile
à traduire c'est un texte qui dit dans
quel ordre il faut faire la cérémonie
il ya un rituel du sacre qui s'est
défini qui a été accentuée qui s'est
développé d'ailleurs au cours du xiiie
siècle et les rituels font que c'est une
garantie de la légitimité
si on suit les rites et rituels ce qui
en ressort est légitime
ce sont des choses très difficile pour
nous à comprendre mais le rituel c'est
fondamental pour le pouvoir politique à
l'époque qui nous intéresse
petit domaine mais grande idée qui fera
petit à petit son chemin dans un monde
féodal instable en recherche d'équilibré
d'autant que le premiers capétiens sait
s'appuyer sur une réponse de l'église
face à cette instabilité
il convient dans un premier temps de
maîtriser la violence de cette société
féodale l'ordre de cluny va aussi
permettre le développement de ce qu'on
appelle la paix de dieu qui va devenir
d'ailleurs à la fin du xième et au début
du 12e siècle à peine du roi qu'est ce
que c'est que la paix de dieu c'est de
développer alors avec l'épiscopat
d'ailleurs un ya pas que les l'abbaye de
cluny qui est en cause de développer
l'idée qu' il y a des des violences qui
ne doivent pas être commise quand elles
sont destinés par exemple contre
l'éclair contre les biens des clercs les
sacrilèges
les marchands les femmes mariées et
pucelle défense de la femme donc les
maisons et les incendies donc y'a pas
que si vous voulez l'aspect purement
religieux c'est une une mise en place
d'un code de ce qui est licite et de ce
qui est lisse illicites comme délit et
s'adonnent à ces délits en caractère
public
le mouvement de la paix de dieu qui
s'officialise h à rouen 989 propose une
organisation sociale reposant sur trois
ordres
le rôle social des chevaliers et de
protéger ceux dont les rôles sociaux
sont de travailler et de prier pour les
opposer aux zones du clergé ou aux
paysans qui sont les travailleurs de la
terre
eh bien ces gens les chevaliers sont des
gens qui sont dans l'armée ce sont des
militaires qui défendent leur seigneur
et qui sont naturellement pour les
différencier également des fantassins
équipé d'un cheval on dit aussi que ce
sont des cavaliers et c'est devenu un
titre de noblesse chevalier titre qui va
rester héréditaire car on pouvait
devenir chevalier deux pères en fils
à condition toutefois de passer dans
cette merveilleuse cérémonie qu'était la
doublement l'église s'était aperçu que
si on privilégiait toujours les
guerriers les plus forts les plus
courageux ou les plus malins ben on
n'aura pas forcément des seigneurs
vertueux est donc cette idée d'avoir des
gens qui seraient élevés selon un code
éthique comme on tirer de nos jours qui
serait à la fois distingué parmi les
guerriers parmi les meilleurs guerriers
mais comme ayant un corps de règles on
dirait faut qu'ils apprennent aussi la
déontologie de la guerre l'esta ce
moment là qu'on a créé les règles
chevaleresque
lorsqu'on était reçue chevalier
lorsqu'ont été fait chevalier
eh bien on était à la fois reconnu comme
quelqu'un de courageux mais aussi
quelqu'un qui avait une formation morale
et religieuse
l'an mil approche alors de plus en plus
de prédication annonce l'apocalypse
mille ans après la mort du christ
en ces temps troublés sur le plan
politique les angoisses n'en sont que
plus exacerbé la conjoncture économique
social et culturel est pourtant
favorable
il ya eu un an mil troué par les
terreurs les terreurs de l'an mil la
comète donc 2014 des famines des
agressions diverses et variées bon
moyennant quoi on a aussi assis
parallèlement une historiographie fondée
sur l'idée que la société féodale est un
nez et actuellement on arrive à une
solution que finalement la société
féodale avait des origines beaucoup plus
lointaine dans l'empiré carolingien dans
le monde dans la société carolingienne
même et que en fait c'est une révolution
lente
c'est à partir du règne de robert 2
qu'on commence à attribuer aux capétiens
des pouvoirs thaumaturgique des dons
miraculeux capable de guérir les
écrouelles fistules purulente due à une
maladie d'origine tuberculeuse
ces guérisons lui valent le surnom de
robert le pieux son fils henri premier
qui l'a fait sacrer de son vivant lui
succède en 1031 ceux pouvant
thaumaturgique aînés on ne sait pas
exactement quand mais on va dire au
cours du 11ème siècle probablement à la
fin du xième siècle il ya bienvenue sous
robert le pieux donc là on est vers 1030
un des récits de miracles du roi mais
qui ne sont pas des miroirs des miracles
bon il aurait rendu la vue à un aveugle
bon ayant un témoignage un seul qui est
celui d'el god fleury un seul manuscrit
en fait petit à petit le miracle royal
se focalise sur lit de la maladie des
glandes du coup qu'on appelle l'escroc
füle les scrofuleux donc et c'est un
miracle qui se poursuit jusqu'à la fin
de la dynastie des des rois de france
c'est à dire que charles disent encore
guéri les écrouelles l'origine delà de
cette croyance elle se situe à kobe rni
où il y aurait eu un loup un loup à la
fois bénéfique et maléfique qui aurait
donné la mali de la maladie d d d escroc
füle donc à aux héritiers des
carolingiens pour favoriser les
capétiens converti au christianisme sous
l'impulsion des ducs
des normands construisent églises et
abbayes et leur foi toute récente n'est
pas perverti
ouais
c'est en voulant effectuer un pèlerinage
en terre sainte quand 1035 meurt le duc
de normandie
robert le magnifique
le fils de robert le magnifique
guillaume aîné au 1022 8c'est héritiers
de ces temps et donc un bâtard robert le
magnifique est un duc de normandie à des
descendants du tout premier de rollon le
rôle on le créateur de la normandie au
traité de saint-clair-sur-epte en leur
911 et robert le magnifique est un homme
qui est un doute qui arrive dans la
ville de falaise qui tombe sous le
charme de la petite arlette de falaise
qui était en train de laver son linge
c'était la fille d'un tanner il va lui
faire un fils mais sans être mariés ils
se mariaient à la mode danoise on disait
à la mode des vikings c'est à dire elle
était sa maîtresse et ce fils va devenir
un bâtard forcément puisqu'il n'avait
pas de parents légitimes de même en
légitime reconnu par l'église et se bat
tarbes sera prénommé guillaume
il ne lui reste plus que sa famille
maternelle c'est elle qui le sauve des
querelles de succession il ne grandit
pas cloisonnés dans le palais ducal
mais au milieu de son peuple et c'est de
là qu'il tire sa crédibilité pour
récupérer son duché
[Musique]
il s'appuie sur ce peuple sur l'église à
qui ils distribuent des biens conséquent
[Musique]
son mariage avec mathilde de flandre
renforce encore une normandie
administrés d'une façon rationnelle et
réunis autour de valeur pure
la normandie est déjà un état moderne
liu est un bâtard mais il connaît le
respect notamment celui du droit féodal
ainsi il ne profite pas d'une victoire
sur le comte d'anjou soutenu par le
capétiens henry premier de france pour
réclamer plus que ce que la logique
féodal lui permet de réclamer
il montre l'exemple du comportement à
adopter dans ce monde féodal en pleine
construction ils respectent la
légitimité d autres éléments de la
pyramide et en premier lieu celle de
l'élément capétiens
[Musique]
sa puissance et son dynamisme font de
l'ombre à henri premier est un cycle roi
d'angleterre edouard le confesseur sans
successeur ayant fait voeu de chasteté a
proposé sa couronne à guillaume ans
qu'il reconnaît un digne successeur afin
de poursuivre la construction de l'état
anglais guillaume le bâtard devient roi
à la mort d'edouard le confesseur 1066
un homme persiste pourtant à se dresser
face au destin de guillaume harold frère
de la reine y exerçant le pouvoir réel
en angleterre à la fin du règne s'empare
de la couronne
tout autant que la logique faire d'al
guillaume tient aux valeurs qui lui sont
associés il se doit de respecter la
promesse faite un homme aussi virtuel
edouard le confesseur et de récupérer
son héritage d'ailleurs guillaume à
l'appui du pape qui lui transmet non
seulement sa manière mais aussi un
cheveu de saint-pierre dans un anneau le
tout consacré de sa main
[Musique]
c'est une croisade avant l'heure que
guillaume prépare méticuleusement avec
tout son peuple
bûcheron et charpentier lui construise
une flotte de 600 navires capables de
transporter des éléments préfabriqués de
fortin des machines de guerre des
chevaux l'approvisionnement de toute une
armée 7000 hommes parmi lesquels
beaucoup de laissés-pour-compte de la
pyramide féodal les fils cadet des
seigneurs de normandie et à qui il
promet un fief sur la terre d'autres
manches
de violents vents contraires repousse le
départ et font croire à un mauvais
présage
ses pressentiments se confirme alors que
la flotte longe la côte à vide et que
d'un second lieu d'embarquement
l'appareillage est toujours impossible
guillaume se décide à organiser avec
toute son armée une procession la nuit
une comète passe dans le ciel et le vent
se met alors au nord
[Musique]
guillaume prend la tête de la flotte sur
le navire battant pavillon pontificale
croix rouge sur fond blanc
le vaisseau amiral est si puissant qu'il
arrive cela l'aube en vue des côtes
anglaises
ce n'est qu'en milieu de matinée que le
reste de la flotte rejoint le bateau de
guillaume et que le débarquement peut
s'effectuer le 29 septembre 1066 harold
n'y croyait plus
de londres il marche avec son armée à la
rencontre de guillaume le bâtard jusqu'à
la colline de hastings d'où ils décident
repousser des vagues normande en
édifiant un triple barrage de flèche
tout d'abord de boucliers et de javelot
dans un second temps enfin pour ceux qui
survivent un troisième rang par
constituer 2h de celle que l'effient
king affectionnait
les vagues sont effectivement repoussé
le chaos est telle dans les rangs
français que l'on croit guillaume morts
il relève la protection nasale de son
casque est à fond de lancer un nouvel
assaut ordonne à ses archers d'incliner
leur tire vers le haut afin de
contourner la muraille de boucliers et
fait abattre une pluie de flèches sur
l'armée anglaise
les flèches tombe du ciel et l'une
d'elles transperce la tête d'harold de
parents barre l'usurpateur est mort et
au soir son triple mur fini par céder
les vagues normande déferle sur toute
l'angleterre
guillaume le bâtard devient guillaume le
conquérant par la volonté de dieu il est
couronné roi d'angleterre le 25 décembre
1066 dans la basilique de wetsminster
guillaume met en place un système féodal
centralisée et donc performant la
rigueur administrative normande traverse
elle aussi la manche et lens
l'angleterre sur la voie du modernisme
politique avec la pierre de caen ont
construit la tour de londres
le français devient la langue officielle
l'anglais n'est plus enseignée utiliser
uniquement par le peuple il se
simplifient c'est un territoire qui
petit à petit adoptera le le les
traditions ont peu vrai dire gallo
romaine
mâtiné de culture franck ce qui faisait
un peu l'originalité du royaume de
france espèce de de bouillonnement de
tradition de droit romain de tradition
guerrière d'héritage gaulois aussi parce
qu'il dans des traditions gauloise qui
sont maintenus mais tout ça et sèmera en
angleterre c'est pourtant durant le
règne de guillaume que les tensions
entre le royaume d'angleterre et celui
de france apparaissent pour s'éterniser
pendant plusieurs siècles
guillaume est roi d'angleterre et la
normandie est quasiment anglaise il est
nul de normandie mais c'est une un bien
de l'angleterre
et c'est une affaire qui va durer
pendant des siècles des siècles qui
entraînera les guerre de cent ans et des
des conflits interminables avec
l'angleterre bien sûr philippe premier
le nouveau roi de france se méfie de l'
influence du conquérant et fait tout
pour la limiter en excitant la crainte
de la bretagne de l'anjou face à cet
ambitieux voisin et en participant
activement à des coalitions anti
normande
il stimule des dissensions à l'intérieur
même de la cellule familiale de
guillaume 20 ans de cette politique
excède le conquérant guillaume prend
conscience de l'impossible cohabitation
entre les deux royaumes
[Musique]
c'est en 1087 sur la route de paris que
son cheval trébuche sur une braise
ardente et qu'ils trouvent la mort
parallèlement au renouveau spirituel
insufflé par cluny une réforme profonde
de l'église chrétienne d'occident
s'organise officiellement et
vigoureusement à partir de rome avec en
1073 le début du pontificat de grégoire
le voyage est assez long dont il ya une
période féodale plus douteuses en faire
on a eu du mal à s'en sortir mais la
réforme grégorienne à chercher justement
à donner la pleine liberté aux abbayes
les sortir de l'autorité des rois ou
comme ici des comtes de toulouse un
schisme a provoqué une rupture entre
rome et constantinople sur le plan
dogmatique une rupture avec les
chrétiens d'orient
ce qui n'empêche pas les alliances
militaires entre chrétiens face à une
menace extérieure à la communauté or
l'empereur d'orient a besoin d aide
cet appel au secours va converger avec
la volonté farouche de l'église de
réformer la société de l'occident
chrétien en novembre 1095 le pape urbain
ii organise un concile à clermont qui
réunit quelques 200 prélat les
principaux hommes influents sur le plan
spirituel en occident ils viennent de
france d'espagne d'italie d'angleterre
aucun ne vient de l'empiré germanique
l'autorité de cette église qui se
réforme a heurté les sensibilités d
empereur germanique
le but est de renforcer la paix de dieu
qui n'est guère respectées
à la fin du concile urbain de lens dans
un prêche en plein air l'idée de la
première croisade il s'agit de libérer
la palestine aux mains des musulmans
depuis 638 de reconquérir les lieux
saints qui ont vu vivre et mourir le
christ mais pour les musulmans aussi
jérusalem est une ville sainte
et pourquoi ils croisade parce que
depuis la mort du christ tout le monde
vivaient en bonne ambiance là bas à
jérusalem les juifs les musulmans les
chrétiens tout le monde vivaient en
bonne ambiance et il ne se passait rien
de dramatique
si ce n'est que à ce moment là à la fin
du xième siècle jérusalem est envahi par
des turcs bifurque au mongol et c'est
turcs vont de massacrer autour d'eux les
musulmans autant que les juifs autant
que les chrétiens et ça ça va se savoir
évidemment sur le continent chez nous et
à ce moment là on se dit il faut aller
aider les chrétiens à jérusalem et
profitons-en donc pour délivrer le
tombeau du christ qui maintenant est aux
mains des infidèles une tournée de
propagande s'organise elle reprend comme
un leitmotiv des exemples du
comportement immonde de ces musulmans
considérés comme des païens idolâtre qui
massacre des chrétiens
tout comme les romains l'avaient fait
avant eux aux origines de la chrétienté
[Musique]
des discours sur la fin des temps
apparaissent des illuminés ou des
visionnaires reprennent en l'amplifiant
le message envoyé par l'église
officielle
la dernière bataille de l'histoire est
pour maintenant
l'idée de croisade combine la notion de
pèlerinage en vue de racheter ses péchés
et celle de guerre sainte
une guerre pour laquelle la violence est
pardonné il est possible maintenant
d'être chrétien et le chevalier la
violence du monde féodal sera canalisé
en dehors de l'occident chrétien et le
chevalier servir à un idéal une
chevalerie du christ avant il défend des
chacun un seigneur terrestre maintenant
ils défendent tous le même seigneur
urbain 2 fait remonter la logique féodal
jusqu'au service de dieu
le service de dieu aura lui aussi sa
rémunération
le salut de l'âme et puis si ce n'est
des chevaliers francs les descendants de
charles martel qui libère jérusalem qui
pourra le faire
surtout qu'une rémunération plus
matérielles et plus immédiate peut être
espérer des terres ou tout simplement la
fortune mais bientôt des exploits
jérusalem et les lieux saints sont
repris par les croisés en 1099 les
croisades donne naissance à une nouvelle
chevalerie avec un code est un principe
de base l'honneur le croisé et marqué du
signe de la croix le capétiens philippe
premier bigame excommunié ne peut
prendre part à la croisade
l'occident est composé de différents
peuples qui n'ont en commun que le
christianisme
la notion de chrétienté n'est de l'idée
de croisade de cet ennemi d'une autre
religion
en passant à côté de cette croisade
capétiens devra attendre la prochaine
pour retrouver une réelle influence sur
le peuple de france il
de nombreuses motivations pu stimuler
ces milliers de croiser de l'aventurier
aux mendiants mais tous étaient en quête
de spiritualité
à la mort de guillaume le conquérant
viendront les problèmes de succession au
royaume d'angleterre qui ne seront
véritablement réglé qu'avec l'accession
au trône de la dynastie plantagenêt mais
c'est l'héritage de guillaume en termes
d'organisation politique qui leur
permettra d'asseoir leur autorité
l'idéal de croisade lui versera tout le
moyen âge et traversera les siècles
l'utilisation du système féodal créé par
guillaume le conquérant avec son
organisation pratique ainsi que l'idéal
de croisade et sa philosophie
permettront aux futurs capétiens de
fédérer et d'asseoir leur autorité sur
un territoire qu'on appelle la france